the king of reality TV just gave us one
of his best episodes yet we will break
down the dock a meeting scene-by-scene
line-by-line democrat humiliation by
democrat humiliation then Allie Stuckey
Bradley Devlin and Jacob Barry joined
the panel of deplorable z' to discuss
Trump's path to firing half of the EPA
staff by the end of his first term
absurd judicial overreach and warren
buffett's warning on Bitcoin
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
what an incredible meeting yesterday at
the White House so for those of you who
didn't see it Donald Trump invited up
congressional leaders Senate leaders and
House leaders from both parties cameras
on he invited the press in the whole
time sitting around the table to talk
about daca and to talk about immigration
this is a signature issue and this is a
very contentious issue and it has been a
contentious issue for almost a century
now and Donald Trump invited everyone in
to do this now that does make him the
most transparent administration in
recent history he has been very open
with the press he'll go on and speak to
them at length without scripts
he's transparent in part because they're
excuse me because there have been so
many leaks also coming from the White
House but contrary to what people
predicted that he would be an autocrat
that he would be a tyrannical he hasn't
been easy open and of course he is we
always should have predicted this he
pioneered a reality television he
pioneered a genre where people invite
cameramen into their homes into their
most private moments into their bedrooms
and let them film him all the time of
course he's going to be transparent
he couldn't be anything but transparent
because if that is his strength playing
to his strengths inviting cameras into
his private life is something he's been
doing since the 1980s so of course he's
going to bring it into his White House
and into his presidency and
unfortunately for some of the
politicians in our room who are not used
to that kind of scrutiny and that kind
of clarity and transparency doesn't
totally play well for them and it really
makes him look good now this is not
completely unprecedented Barack Obama
held up one sort of similar meeting
during his push for health cared for
Obama care but he totally botched
here's Obama know that geography does
not dictate what kind of health care
they would receive Thank You mr.
president
look let me just make this point John
because we're not campaigning the
election is over
that that a total botch I mean
absolutely awful that's probably why he
didn't make it a regular feature of his
presidency and why he presided over one
of the least transparent administrations
in American history he is there he can't
help but be this crass and mean
politician because all Barack Obama
knows from his entire life is politics
he all he ever did was write about
himself and why he should be elected
president before he actually was elected
to Illinois State Senate and then the
Senate for five seconds and then the
presidency so he has to get those Barb's
all he knows is that little political
attack Donald Trump knows much more than
that he knows how to entertain and he
has been a businessman for his entire
adult life so he it just allows him to
interact with people and to interact
with the cameras much better here is
Trump here's how he opens well thank you
very much everyone for being here I'm
thrilled you do with a distinguished
group of Republican and Democratic
lawmakers from both the House and the
Senate we have something in common we
would like to see this get done and you
know what this means we are here today
to advance bipartisan immigration reform
that serves the needs of the American
families workers and taxpayers
it's duhkha we've been talking about
doctor for a long time I've been hearing
about it for years long before I decided
to go into this particular line of work
and maybe we can do something we have a
lot of good people in this room a lot of
people that have a great spirit for
taking care of people we represent we
all represent so you have Barack Obama
in a similar sort of meeting and he says
well John the campaigns over when I am
the president why I won this was for
bribry right and Donald Trump opens up
in a completely different turn the
opposite tone he says we have a lot of
good people here this problem has
preceded me it's been around long before
I was around as president and so you
know we're going to take on this
together I didn't ask to take this I
didn't create the problem but now I'm in
this line of work we're gonna do it so
what are the priorities the border
security agents the ice agents we have
to give them the
equipment they need we have to close
loopholes and this really does include a
very strong amount of different things
for border security I think everybody in
the room would agree to that I think
that we it's a question of amounts but I
think everyone agrees we have to have
border security I don't think it'd be
anybody that says no everybody agrees
right we all we totally agree on that
this is a verbal tic particularly of New
Yorkers but it's really fun and
transparent and effective my
step-brother and I you know in New York
we would do this to each other all the
time say hey so I can have some of your
whiskey yeah oh hey I can have your
cigar what'd you do by saying look we
all agree on this we're really just
debating about this you're assuming the
premise you're making people assume a
premise that they might otherwise not
take Donald Trump does this all the time
by the way he blows past premises and
gets you to negotiating on his own terms
so the most famous example is the
central campaign promise we're going to
build the wall and Mexico will pay for
it that's the great example before
Donald Trump building a wall across the
southern border of the United States was
a very controversial position many
people opposed it even within the
Republican Party Donald Trump didn't say
I'm gonna build a wall and that's my
strong point he said of course we're
gonna build the wall the question is
just who's gonna pay for it and he's
gonna make apparently ridiculous claim
of who's going to pay for it so the
whole conversation became about who
would pay for the wall
they just swallowed that they're going
to build the wall whole cloth now what
else will be in the final agreement want
to see chain migration ended and we have
a recent case along the West Side
Highway having to do with chain
migration where a man ran over killed
eight people and many people injured
badly loss of arms loss of legs horrible
thing happened and then you look at the
chain and all the people that came in
because of him
terrible situation and the or the other
is to cancel the lottery program they
call it Visa Lottery I just call it
lottery but countries come in and they
put names in a hopper they're not giving
you their best
name's common-sense means they're not
giving you their best names they're
giving you people that they don't want
and then we take him out of the lab
lottery and when they do it by hand
where they put the hand in a bowl I
probably what's in the hand or the worst
of the worst
notice the graphic vivid language he
opens up so he's been so nice we have a
lot of great people in the room and then
he opens up and immediately ties the
issue of the the border wall and the
dreamer Dhaka people these people who
were brought into the United States
before they were fully grown adults he
ties it to a terrorist attack in New
York a radical Muslim terrorist attack
that happened just last year and he's
talking about body parts flying away we
really grow stuff but things that create
a very vivid picture in your mind he
then moves on to the lottery and he says
some people call it the Visa Lottery I
call it the lottery and by the way
there's no difference here right there's
he's not actually making any categorical
distinction or substantive difference
between the two he just knows that the
language of Visa Lottery you kind of
your eyes glaze over what's a visa
exactly I know it has to do with
immigration and travel but for most
Americans they just okay I guess but he
says it's the lottery like when you go
buy a lottery ticket and he's got this
image of your hand reaching into the
bowl and I yes one Juan Lopez Gonzalez
he's gonna come in now and reaching into
the bowl because that is absurd and the
end the lottery system as it currently
stands is absurd and he's drawing that
comparison he's all of these images are
floating around in your mind so that's
how he frames a discussion then he turns
the cameras on the people in the room we
also as you know it was passed in 2006 a
essentially similar thing they fence a
very substantial fence was passed but
unfortunately I don't know they never
got it done but they need it that's the
beginning of that line they all the
politicians are all talk
Donald Trump is a man of action all talk
no action politicians and then Donald
Trump but he points out he says you know
you already voted for this you already
voted for this a lot of Democrats
already voted for that he starts calling
them out because he says look this isn't
me just being crazy and you're all
dealing with me being crazy what he what
you have done is what I am now executing
you talked a lot about it now we're
make it happen that's why we brought you
here and as a matter of fact speaking of
that isn't it a little curious who's
sitting right next to him thanks mr.
president for inviting us were honored
to be part of this conversation
September the fifth you challenges to
challenge Congress you said we're going
to end daca and now replace it as of
today we've not done that dick durbin is
sitting right next to him he's the
assistant Democrat leader the second
highest ranking Democrat in the Senate
but it's not Chuck Schumer by the way
it's not the leader it's the assistant
it's a guide to Trump his reigning
supreme here but to his right he's got
the second highest ranking Democrat in
the Senate and by the way on his other
side is Steny Hoyer another Democrat the
Democrat minority whip one of the
highest ranking Democrats in Congress
but it isn't it isn't Chuck and Nancy
it's not Nancy Pelosi they lost their
chance these are guys that we can make a
deal with and listen to how respectful
they are to him it isn't the resistance
we're expecting yeah show him shove it
right in his eyes you have a fork in his
eye the resistance and then he says oh
thank you for inviting us here though we
didn't expect this maybe the government
is being run differently than the
mainstream media are telling us
Democrats can't back away here they
can't back away they're framed exactly
on either side of him
they are part of this and and what they
get out of it is that they look like
they have a seat at the table they get
some credibility they're not just
screaming little children that Donald
Trump is showing them some respect and
they're going to have to show him some
respect in return if they don't want to
get booted out of the room like Chuck
and Nancy so let's turn to the other
side and talk to Steny Hoyer in my view
we can pass we can pass the protection
in the what I understand your position
is procedurally it was not done
correctly you then as dick has said
challenged us pass it correctly that's
incredible you now have the Democrat
House whip basically admitting the
Barack Obama violated the law he's
saying this wasn't done correctly
that wasn't Barack Obama and didn't do
this correctly now we have to do it
correctly I wonder if this was scripted
if these points these talking points
were agreed upon by these three men
ahead of
clearly some terms work read upon for
these opening remarks that in itself is
a significant deal saying we'll give you
this we'll give you this public showing
if you give us this public showing it's
not like they went in there an ad lib
that they had all of this scripted out
the question is what did they each know
about where it was going to go you'll
see at some points in the conversation
the conversation gets sidetracked this
meeting goes off the rails a little bit
they pull it back in but a lot of it is
pre scripted so Trump in his typically
subtle way didn't want anybody to miss
the point that the Democrat to his left
just made I agree with him on that issue
and interestingly when you say that
President Obama when he signed the
executive order actually said he doesn't
have the right to do this and so you do
have to go through Congress and you do
have to make it permanent just in case
you missed that we wouldn't want you to
miss that we want anybody to miss what
he just said but now notice how
reasonable Donald Trump sounds as he's
making that point is he saying Barack
Obama is a dirty criminal liar and it
was how reasonable that Michael Wolf
booked that tabloid trash has alleged
that Donald Trump is a screaming baby
he's all emotion he's all reactive
totally impulsive he can barely form a
sentence we're not seeing that here not
only is he calm he's conducting this
discussion like an adult like he's the
adult in the room he's even being
conciliatory we also know by the way
little sidebar we know that the claim
about Trump being impulsive reckless
emotional we know that isn't true
because of Steve Bannon because of how
Donald Trump treated Steve Bannon Bannon
was making a lot of shaky comments
negative comments leaking things to
Donald Trump since the moment he was
fired even before he was fired but
Donald from held his fire he said okay
we're not gonna play around just yet it
was only after abandoned lost Alabama
incredibly a Herculean task and
achievement for a Republican to lose
Alabama so he's at his lowest point
professionally and he calls Trump and
his family traitors then he drops the
hammer but he a lot all of this
president ban and Trump doesn't know
anything he's just a vessel for my
movement he let that slide he played
very nicely while Bannon was still
relatively loyal and then he pounced but
that was planned out that wasn't just
emotional one night he got angry and
tweeted at Bannon
so that you can have one or the other
but you can't have both criticism
simultaneous leave Donald Trump okay
mister conciliator
let's get some people on the record okay
sure would agree to that also but we'll
do it in steps and most people agree
with that I think they'll do the steps
even you said let's do this and then we
go Phase two Kevin what would you like
to say he's like a parent mediating
between children we've been told that
he's the child dealing with him is like
dealing with the child but that's not
we're saying I say look this is and and
as you said as you have already said we
need to do this and we're gonna have to
negotiate and do this but he's the he's
the one there right in the middle
he's even mediating between people
within their own parties so now that the
stage is set let's start talking about
the legislative solution itself well I
think a good starting point would be Bob
Goodlatte is done a bill and I
understand you're ready to submit it and
you're gonna take that and you'll submit
and they'll negotiate in Congress in the
house and then it goes through the
Senate they'll negotiate both Republican
and Democrat but it could be a good way
of starting now if anyone has an idea
different from that but I think starting
in the house starting at the house might
be good you're ready I think you're
ready to go you know I would like to add
the words merit into any bill that's
submitted because I think we should have
merit-based immigration like they have
in Canada like you have in Australia so
we have people coming in that have a
great track record as opposed to as
opposed to what we're doing now to be
honest with you oh I don't know that
seems like a good solution hey guys just
off the top of my head I'm just
spitballing here how about we start with
the Republican plan for immigration a
doc but we do that obviously we're gonna
start with good lads bill but and and
what Trump does is he immediately
appears to break with it so he's sort of
playing that I don't know just came to
my top of my head but you know by the
way before we do we're gonna have to add
merit that all of these conversations
have already happened this is totally
performed for the cameras it's the
performance of reality for the cameras
gee who would be good at performing
reality on television I don't Kim then
his name escapes me of course so
nobody's gonna disagree with that but
did you catch his other line he says
does anybody else have a bill to start
with does anybody else does anybody else
have another idea the cameras
Ron here's your chance you're always
complaining you're always saying that
we're not listening to you and you're
being shut out what's your plan do you
have any plans and the Democrats are
dead silent throughout the meeting Trump
does is hey Johnny Sally do you want to
add something do you want to speak you
know because when you go on CNN later
you're gonna say that we shut you up so
here's your chance speak up if you have
anything absolutely not it's easy to
shriek resist and resist on CNN but now
it's much harder now it is much more
difficult when the cameras are on you
and you actually have to legislate so
now we get to precisely what Donald
Trump wants the public to take away from
this meeting he gets things done he is
not an all talk no action politician he
does things take it away you know one of
the reasons I'm here Chuck so
importantly is exactly that I mean
normally you wouldn't have a president
coming to this meeting
normally frankly you'd have Democrats
Republicans and maybe nothing would get
done you know our system lends itself to
not getting things done and I hear so
much about earmarks the old earmark
system how there was a great
friendliness when you had here marks but
of course they had other problems with
the earmarks but maybe all of you should
start thinking about going back to a
form of earmarks because this system
this system
you should do it and I'm there with you
because this sense of the system really
lends itself to not getting along it
lends itself to hostility and anger and
they hate the Republicans of a hate the
Democrats and you know in the old days
of earmarks you can say what you want
about certain presidents and others
where they all talk about they went out
to dinner at night and they all got
along and they passed bills that was an
earmark system and maybe we should think
about it and we have to put better
controls because it got a little bit out
of hand but maybe that brings people
together I love it I think Donald Trump
is the first president in history to
publicly campaign on earmarks that we
need more earmarks the reason this
sounds a little strange an earmark is
pork barrel spending is what they call
it right and it says well if you come
over on this piece of legislation for me
and I'll give you I'll vote for the post
office in your district and then we can
both benefit and get reelected right
John McCain turned the Republican and
conservative opinion against this when
he ran for president he turned a lot of
Republicans against earmarks because for
one precise reason because John McCain
is a big government spend a lot of money
Republican he's a liberal Republican so
he knew that if he was gonna run against
spending he couldn't run against the
actual drivers of the debt and deficit
which are Medicare Medicaid Social
Security big entitlement programs big
federal programs he couldn't run against
military spending John McCain is one of
the biggest Hawks in the United States
Senate so he had to run against the alt
the only other little spending which is
pork barrel spending the irony is though
that pork barrel spending those earmarks
really didn't constitute even a blip on
the federal budget that was a little
slush here and there to make votes
easier but all of the drivers are those
federal programs that John McCain
supports so it was a big distraction at
distracted Republicans for a couple
election cycles but we shouldn't be
distracted by that the earmarks are
nothing compared to the big challenges
which are federal regulation massive
federal program spending and then
entitled entitlement spending which
actually drives our deficits so Trump
here then Trump negotiates negotiation
itself this is pretty masterful
there are some things that you're
proposing they're going to be very
controversial and will be an impediment
to agreement but you're gonna negotiate
those things you're gonna sit down
either say listen we can't agree here we
will give you a half of that we're gonna
negotiate the president's comprehensive
means comprehend so we're not talking
about doctrine oh now we're talking
about we are we are talking about
conferencing good why go there it's okay
cuz you're not that far president many
of the things that are mentioned ought
to be a part of the negotiations
regarding comprehensive immigration with
it if you want to take it this step
further you may I'm gonna have to rely
on you which is you very complicated and
you may delay daca somewhat so if you
just miss that heap it's the Democrat
congressional leaders against one
another with the entire American public
watching in the entire press corps
filming the whole thing so he says oh
you want comprehensive immigration
reform is that where this conversation
is going sure we all want that but that
may delay daca you know that thing that
we're all here talking about that you
insisted we talk about well we made
delay daca and there's that threat and
it's not a fire and fury threat it's
it's legitimately a subtle threat so you
you have then on the other side dick
Durbin so the Democrat dick Durbin says
no no we're not talking about
comprehensive we're talking about daca
shut up Steny we stay focused and it's
great because it makes them look like
they're squabbling they don't have their
act together they don't have their
agenda together Trump split some and so
he's putting a wedge between them great
job this is one of the biggest wins for
the Republicans in the meeting it gave
Democrats the opportunity to humiliate
themselves here is Democrat Henry
Cuellar if you look at the latest DEA
view worried about drugs look at the
latest DEA report more drugs come
through the ports of entry than in
between ports but we're not even talking
about ports of entry number one and some
of us have been working this longer than
some other folks number one if you look
at the 11 to 12 million undocumented
aliens which is a second face 40% of
them came through visa overstay so you
can put the most beautiful wall out
there it's not going to stop them there
because Oh either come by plane boat or
or vehicle itself the other thing is the
other thing that we got to look at the
wall itself mr. president you talked to
your mortar Patrol chief or the former
Border Patrol chiefs I've asked them how
much time does a wall by you they'll say
a couple minutes or a few seconds it is
our own Border Patrol chiefs that have
said that but Smackdown Smackdown smack
daddy brings up a point nope not true
brings him another point no sorry also
not true and he has to say cuz he's a
politician so he can't say oh well I
didn't know that he says oh yeah I know
no you didn't know you just contradicted
the point you just said something that
is demonstrably false and then you were
contradicted that's not even all of the
stupid platitudes and talking points
that this guy dropped well are said he
said we're playing defense on the
one-yard line with border security
look how Mexico stopped immigration on
their southern border Trump points out
they didn't stop immigration on their
border we stopped immigration on their
border because overall illegal
immigration has dropped since Donald
Trump was elected president so obviously
the people who were that no one's
immigrating to Mexico because Mexico is
a nice place
Mexico is a terrible country and it's
not enjoyable to live in people are
going through Mexico to get to the
United States which is Mecca right it's
just hedges this heaven Lake the lovely
place that everybody in the hemisphere
wants to go to so Trump points that out
he he and this is a rare interjection
for him he's been letting them just
smack each other around the whole
meeting george w bush a great man but
not great at this he never answered
their stupid talking points you know he
Donald Trump invites them all to come in
in front of the cameras and then he
smacks them down himself and he allows
them to hit each other a few major
takeaways here one Trump has a grasp of
issues contrary to popular media
reporting he has a grasp of the issues
at one point when Kevin Brady and Dianne
Feinstein started fighting Kevin
McCarthy rather sums up what they want
and Trump adds another ending the
lottery system it makes Democrats put up
or shut up it involves them in the
government so so much for the resistance
right they're flanking him left and
right he appears at least as impressive
and actually more impressive than all of
those people I say more impressive only
because they seem stiff a lot of the
people in that room like like quail or
Henry Cuellar is a good example or Steny
Hoyer dick Durbin they're they're
they're off batter fighting they go a
little off balance and we can see that
the mainstream media cannot convincingly
lie about what we see with our own eyes
most important takeaway as the
mainstream media breathlessly reports
the admitted lies in that tabloid book
the meeting makes Trump look less scary
to the American people
Barak Obama did this it was one of his
great achievements in the 1990s with his
first memoir he you know he released
this memoir Dreams from My Father
during that explosion of memoirs by not
famous people there was a opinion
fever-pitch the the diving bell and the
butterfly the kiss all these memoirs in
the 1990s of just regular people and
Barack Obama released and he said yeah I
did coke and I ate dogs and Indonesian
and I did this a man isn't that my
father was a bigamist and everything but
a real master stroke by the end of that
book you're not afraid of Barack Obama
he isn't scary so he did that memoir
form in the 1990s during that explosion
Donald Trump doesn't with reality
television he brings in his strength his
preferred medium reality TV and it makes
him less scary by the end of that
meeting okay let's bring on our panel
but before before we get to the panel
let's talk about looking good on camera
so one way if you want to look good on
camera I'll tell you you need a good
shave you need to you know you've got to
pamper yourself a little bit clean your
hair wash your face and shave now Dollar
Shave Club is an amazing opportunity
they're there razors are excellent and
you know now when you go to stores
they'll still have like the 75 blade
razor that costs a gazillion dollars and
you know they just keep adding all these
blades to make it seem like a better
shave that's really all they can add in
the product so a Dollar Shave Club is
like the perfect razor and it's really
good especially when you use it with dr.
Carver's shave butter so I am NOT going
to give up my membership and there are
even more dollar shave club products
that you can add to your routine
so these guys started out it was this
great thing you just get shavers and the
male razors in the mail you don't need
to
about it I never run out to the store
I'm using old blades in the old days you
know old blades from three years ago
don't do that just don't think about it
you'll get them in the mail there on
time but now Dollar Shave Club has a lot
more products say products for your hair
face skin shower they have everything
you need I do not go to drug stores or
pharmacies and just get it mailed to you
it's much much easier it's a 21st
century folks take advantage of our
technology so they only use the finest
premium ingredients and they deliver it
to you just like they do their razors no
more trying annoying trips to the store
going up and down the aisles is it on
aisle 7 is it on hour 12 you have to
stand in line for three hours at my
local drugstore I won't say the name of
it so I used Dollar Shave but for all of
those things razors body cleanser hair
gel they even have a new product I don't
even know if I can say this on the air
it's a little personal you know bathroom
things were a little personal but you
know sometimes you know in Europe they
use bidets to clean themselves after
they use the facilities Dollar Shave
love makes that even easier it's much
more American gets delivered to you it's
worth it let's be clean everybody it's
really good mails right to your door so
they have you covered head to toe and
now is a great time to give Dollar Shave
Club a try you can get your first month
of their best razor along with travel
sized versions of shave butter body
cleanser and yes even that little
cleanser for your derriere for just five
dollars so just do it I mean this it's
practically free go there right now
after that the replacement car which was
your ship for just a few bucks a month
it will save you time it will save you
money it is a no-brainer and that that
first order is practically free it is
the daily shave club Dollar Shave Club
starter set I get yours for just $5
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com slash
CoV fe fe co5 a Dollar Shave Club comm
slash cuff fa what is that Marshall
dollar just leave dollarshaveclub.com
slash go f f/a why do we keep him around
here I'm gonna you're gonna have to pay
$10 for that Marshall everyone else is
just $5 okay let's bring on the panel we
have got today
Bradley Devlin Jacob airy and most
exciting of all Allie Stuckey everybody
thank you for being here Allie
congratulations by the way
I know that you now have a show on CR TV
yes I do I do I'm very excited I'm
excited for you to show me the podcast
ropes that's Melanie I don't know I
don't know anything about it I you know
I some people ask me for advice on how
to publish a book I don't know anything
about books I wrote a book with nowt any
words this one I guess this has some
more words really just take a lot of
cough fi and it will it will help you in
your podcasting skills what's the show
gonna look like perfect well I'm not
exactly sure yet so we can decide videos
I'll be yes exactly I'll be doing a to
shorter videos week and then every two
and a half weeks there will be a longer
floor video and it'll be a variety of
different things and then it'll be a
weekly podcast so I'm not up to the
level that you are of a daily podcast
it'll be a weekly podcast you know not
everyone can do it but it's God's really
some of us are called to do to spread
the cough FA that is good this actually
might get me to subscribe to see our TV
I you know I I don't use I use Crowder's
mug as an ashtray when I smoke cigars so
what I'm gonna do for that obviously but
but now that you're there I'm much more
compelled to do and Robbie that's right
roaming Millennials getting a show - all
right well both of you together I guess
that's that's a pretty good argument to
do it despite not gay Jarrod and crowd
are being over there - okay well listen
I know that you all on Facebook and
YouTube want to hear from the panel we
have to talk about this stupid judge in
the middle of San Francisco ruling
against daca and preventing Donald Trump
from executing his office because we've
elected him to do that there are a lot
of other things we're gonna talk about a
Bitcoin in a little bit we're also gonna
talk about Donald Trump just burning the
government to the ground and firing all
these useless bureaucrats up but you
don't get that unless you subscribe to
daily wire.com
if you subscribe what do you get well
you get me you get the intercalated show
you get the Ben Shapiro show all of that
is well and good but forget about it
what you really need is this because
that meeting that that daca meeting that
we all just walk
through and analyzed we're gonna get
that wall folks and when that wall goes
up it's actually gonna make the floods
of left us tears even worse because
there's gonna be nowhere for the tears
to go that can't go down and flood
Mexico and Central and South America
they're going to be stuck here and you
are going to want to protect yourself
and protect your family with the leftist
yours tumbler so go to daily wire comm
right now we'll be right back
[Music]
okay so this San Francisco District
Judge William
alsep a Clinton appointee has
temporarily blocked President Trump from
phasing out daca Bradley what is this
about what is the judicial argument for
blocking the end of a totally
unconstitutional immigration power grab
well first thanks for having me on
Michael I have had a great time on
winter break watching all this
conservative policy go through it's it's
been a great turn of events from Twitter
trolling to actual policy it's fantastic
you know we've been getting both great
seeing Bannen implode anyway the
legalities behind the injunction too and
the daca rescinding from the Trump
administration if you actually read I
was reading some of the excerpts from
his 49 page ruling this argument looks
exactly like the argument a conservative
judge would make when Obama was pushing
through daca using prosecutorial
discretion back in 2012
mm-hmm and so it says that Alsip said in
the in the injunction plaintiffs have
shown that they are likely to succeed on
the merits of their claim that recension
rescission was arbitrary and capricious
hmm that's interesting the anomaly of
the arbitrary and capricious when
deciding that they weren't gonna uphold
the rule of law and give and give
amnesty to all these daca recipients who
can now work have papers and receive
welfare that was practically the Obama
campaign slogan Obama 2012 arbitrary and
capricious right just to say that the
injunction was appropriate because our
country has a strong interest in the
uniform application of immigration law
and policy oh my gosh are you kidding
this is insane okay you cannot say that
you want to have the uniform application
of immigration law on policy because if
that was the case you'd be on the ann
coulter train and say deport all of them
it doesn't matter right though is clear
and the law is clear folks well this
brings up a problem really because the
law contradicts all of these regulations
that came out of the executive so I do
see a certain argument saying well we
made this promise we made this
executive regulation and even though
that itself contradicts law you
violating that would pose other legal
problems Jacob is this a problem with
the judiciary or with the regulatory
state both it's a problem that the
executive branch was basically Congress
gave this power to President Obama even
when the Republicans were in charged
mama would say oh I'm gonna write out an
executive order and the Republicans just
went okay but then on the on the flip
side when Trump actually says hey I'm
going to give this power back to
Congress a judge can say no you can't
give that power back to Congress why
it's what universe are we living in I
don't think that the San Francisco
federal judge even has the authority to
do this so if I was president Trump
course this is probably very unwise
advice but I'd be like okay you made
this ruling now you have to enforce it
because it's completely an illegal it's
a completely an illegal ruling he has no
basis for this and it makes no sense as
far as the Constitution goes and it'll
be overturned
it'll I'm not worried about it he's
making some stupid point and that this
is what gets to it Ally lest we become
all talk and no action to quote a great
man how do we combat this sort of absurd
judicial overreach absolutely I think
Senator Cornyn actually said it best he
said it's absolutely ridiculous to think
that Obama can create something that
President Trump can't uncreate that's
just not how it works and what I think
is interesting about this as well is
that this judge and I think previous
judges but this judge I know is using
Trump's recent tweets to try to
psychoanalyze his motive behind
rescinding this so Trump tweeted not too
long ago that he basically wants the
dreamers to stay that all of these well
accomplished dreamers that have
contributed so much to society are we
really going to deport them which was
kind of amazing when he tweeted that but
he did and so this judge is basically
saying look the president really wants
them to stay the only thing that he is
trying the only reason he's trying to
rescind
for the illegality and it is not what
this judge is trying to say is that it
is not the executive branch's role to
say whether something is illegal or not
it is the Supreme Court's role what do
you think is completely hypocritical
because of this guy if this judge was so
concerned with legality illegality
something being constitutional if he
would have really similar concerns when
Obama was passed in the first place
outside exactly what Bradley was saying
and I think that's funny and that's a
trend that we see kind of across the
board and I just realized that I'm not
really answering your question I'm just
talking a lot an interesting trend that
we're seeing with all these judges that
are pushing back on uh on Trump's
attempt at immigration reform is that
they all of the sudden care about
constitutionality they all the sudden
care about legality and following the
rule of law they all the sudden have all
of these concerns about keeping our
democratic system and why when they
never had those concerns when they
agreed with the policies that that Obama
was you know unilaterally pushing
through completely unconstitutionally so
I think that point alone just shows that
this is a completely partisan move that
like you said I think will be overture
where absolutely and there and there are
two lines of attack here as well so
obviously one is nominating original
ists to the court people who and texture
lists to the court people who believe
that words have meaning Constitution has
a meaning and the words of laws have
meanings that we cannot just interpret
willy-nilly however we'd like that's one
track the other is to reduce the size of
the regulatory state so that we defer
less to them on the execution of their
own policies so that the courts defer
less to them over democratically enacted
laws and that takes me into the next
news story the Washington Examiner
yesterday reported that Donald Trump's
EPA is on track to cut 47% of the EPA
staff by the end of his first term
that's just through retirement that's
just through attrition losing people
regularly we're talking about losing
seven or eight thousand people at the
EPA even Ronald Reagan the
greatest American president of his
century at least did not reduce the size
of the government Ali will Trump reduce
the size and scope of the federal
government finally yeah so I'm Scott
Pruitt was saying that the reason for
this like you said it's through
retirement and through just shrinking
the agency in general the reason for
this is because they want to go back to
the basics when it comes to these
regulations and protecting the
environment I mean I think that there is
a very careful balance of trying to
protect the environment through
common-sense regulations perhaps and not
seeing it in the way of job creation and
we know that that's a top priority of
this president and the administration
and this agency hasn't been as small as
it's supposed to be I think it's around
14,000 since Ronald Reagan was president
which is pretty incredible especially
for all of the people that keep on
saying that trumps a Democrat Trump's
not a conservative I was one of those
people but if you look at his track
record especially with diminishing the
scope of the government I mean he's one
of one of the most if not the most
conservative president that we've had in
decades right absolutely right and I was
surprised too I fell for that Donald
Trump is a lifelong New Yorker he won't
really cut the government we're seeing
these lievable cuts and this does lead
to a question Jacob why have passed
Republican presidents not reduced the
size of the government honestly think
it's because of laziness outside of the
Juke ol Ronald Reagan lazy how dare you
well Ronald Reagan actually he had a
Democrat Congress and so in that case it
was the Congress being being competitive
but I own it but I honestly think that's
what it is I mean we saw when certainly
when President George W Bush was in
power he had a Republican Congress for a
while and he didn't shrink the EPA and I
really think that that's what it is you
get distracted and of course you know
with President Bush we had the war in
Iraq and the war in Afghanistan and it
which grew the government to some extent
so I honestly think it's not some sort
of malicious thing but I just think oh
well shrinking the EPA well that really
affect my numbers yeah probably not so
I'm just gonna let it be and there is a
question I mean we don't you don't
exactly need Congress to fire people
within your own branch of the government
right there is a you know these guys are
feds I once got to talk to Antonin
Scalia and we asked about states rights
he said states rights are dead they've
been dead since the 17th amendment and
the direct election of senators what are
you going to look to me to protect
states rights I'm a Fed I work for the
federal government and there is an
aspect of a president coming into office
and saying you know it is sure helpful
if I've got all of these big agencies
there so that I can wield my own power
for perfectly good policy let's say but
it's it's much harder to say we're just
going to cut people we're gonna fire
we're gonna not replace people after
they retire and at least for this first
year these first twelve months we have
seen historic cuts in the federal
government and we can only hope that
they continue let's move on and finally
in our in our last minutes let's move on
to something that that is unrelated I
suppose to Donald Trump but it's I've
resisted running this story I know a lot
of conservatives and Republicans they've
gotten very into crypto currencies
they've gotten into Bitcoin people
invested thirty five cents in Bitcoin
ten years ago and they're now gazillion
errors there now richer than Warren
Buffett but Warren Buffett the Oracle of
Omaha has is now saying that crypto
currencies are headed for trouble that
it won't end well the the Bitcoin surge
is now much much larger than even the
tulip a bubble in Holland I've been
referring to them as a digital beanie
babies Bradley you're a youth you're a
young kid or people of your generation
people at college campuses young
conservatives are they investing in
crypto currencies and or they are they
afraid of losing all of their money
they're obsessed I mean my friend just
became a miner the other day my buddy is
the chairman of the blockchain at
Berkeley Club and we've been talking for
a long time about about Bitcoin because
I'm really struggling to understand it
because when we're learning about money
in classic economics classes there's two
types of money there's fiat money which
it's government its value is determined
by government institutions that back it
and then there's commodity money which
means that that money or that money or
exchange piece holds intrinsic value and
can be used and therefore is worth
something
Bitcoin is none of those things in
either
commodity money the only thing that this
thing applies to in classical economics
isn't supply demand graph it derives its
value from people being willing to
supply it and people people demanding it
um and so that that's see really
seriously problematic when we're talking
about money because Bitcoin rapidly
appreciates when there's a good article
about it when consumer demand goes up
but then drastically drops from they
can't maintain that hype and when you
can't maintain that hype that money's
not going through a money multiplier
system we're not going to have
cryptocurrency basic societies in the
future it's foolish to think other of
course it isn't a currency it doesn't
meet any criteria of currencies and it
also isn't even an asset it is just
speculation and look I like going to
casinos as much as the next guy so if
you've made money gambling good on you
but it isn't yeah one one kind of wacky
conservative investment I made is I
bought a bunch of rhodium which is a
precious metal and I have a bar of
rhodium and I made a hundred percent
return last year so I've only been
referring to that as coin coin this is a
newfangled thing where you get a
physical asset that you can invest in
alley or crypto currencies are they just
a fad and they're gonna go bust have to
understand it I think the bradley did a
very good job of explaining why this is
so confusing to me I mean God just did
not create my brain to understand
cryptocurrency
therefore I want nothing to do with it
and if Warren Buffett says that it's a
bad that I don't need to pay attention
to that means that I'm a good company
maybe I do understand it a lot more than
other people do and that's why I don't
want to spend any time thinking about it
yeah yeah not only did he say that wants
nothing to do with it
he himself said I don't understand this
thing when one Buffett says I don't
understand we're gonna find out Donald
Trump has just stores and stores hard
drives and servers full of Bitcoin that
stable genius all right panel that's all
our time thank you for being here
excellent to have all of you today
that's our entire show make sure to tune
into another Kingdom by the way so
another Kingdom is back after the
Christmas break and Hollywood I don't
want to tell tales out of school
I even talked about this on his show the
other day Hollywood which saw the
immense popularity of this podcast the
narrative podcast I'm doing with Andrew
Klavan they saw it it's got I think
1,600 five-star reviews now it's got a
lot of downloads very very popular
always charting on iTunes they called us
in to pitch this for television and then
I think that googled Andrew Clavin and
then the meet they were all cold
meetings we found out one of the
production companies now as part of the
resistance or something like that it is
really crazy
so please shove it down their throats
please send another Kingdom
dear friends write a review tweet it
bows to get it out there subscribe
because the bigger that this project has
gotten the the more Hollywood wants to
put its finger in its ears and say
lalalalala we won't have any
conservative art here no lalala look at
my lapel pin in my black clothing lalala
so please help us shove it down their
throats we really appreciate that
get your mailbag questions in for
Thursday I'm Michael Moses the Michael
Mel show see you tomorrow
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua
of era the Michael Dahl show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for word publishing 2018